People are building 3D models in Blender
just by typing. Filing taxes
automatically. Scraping Instagram for
restaurant recommendations all with one
tool. [music] And most people don't even
know it exists. I'm not technical at
all. I avoided this for months thinking
it wasn't for me. Then I figured out the
truth. You don't need to write a single
line of code. I use a version of this
system to make videos for this channel.
A lot of you have been asking how. Today
I'm showing you the foundation. By the
end of this video, you'll have one, a
personal AI assistant that remembers
everything about your projects. Two,
your first AI agent built and deployed.
Three, a full content army working on
autopilot. All with just three commands.
The tool cla code. And I'm not just
going to tell you about it. I'm going to
build the whole thing live right now.
Let me prove it.
Now, most of you might be thinking, "Oh,
Vehav, Claude in the browser works just
fine for me. Why should I even switch to
Claude code?" Let me break it down
simply. Claude in the browser, that's
Tony Stark without the suit. Genius. Can
solve most problems. But there's a
limit. He gets tired. He can only be in
one place. He forgets things between
conversations. Now, Claude Cod is the
full Iron Man suit with Jarvis builtin,
unlimited capabilities, a genius AI
assistant that remembers everything, has
access to all your files, never loses
context, and everything is saved on your
own computer. Jarvis doesn't forget.
Javis knows your preferences. Javis can
run your entire workshop while you focus
on the big picture. Tony without the
suit versus Iron Man with Javis. That's
the difference. And today, you're
getting your suit.
Now let's install and set up claude
code. There are two ways to do this.
First way, go to the link, copy the
respective command for Mac or Windows
and paste it in your terminal. I know
terminal can be scary and intimidating.
So there's an easier, simpler way. Just
download the Claude desktop app on your
computer. Once done, just loging in with
your Claude account. So Claude code is
only available on the paid plans. You
can get started with Claude Pro that
cost $20 per month. Just as I was
recording this video, Claude announced
Claude Co-work. That's Claude Code
specifically built for non-developers.
But as of now, it's only available on
Mac [music] and you need a $100 Claude
Max subscription to run it. For this
video, we're using regular Claude code,
which works on both Mac and Windows with
the $20 pro plan. Let's suit up.
Now, here's something that blew my mind.
>> Tell me about you. What do you like?
What do you do at Anthropic? Like, how
are you involved in this?
>> How am I involved in this? Um, I've been
at Anthropic for a little bit, but uh
this is the product that my team has
built here. We sprinted at this for the
last week and a half. Um, what we're
trying
>> last week and a half,
>> that's an anthropic employee, the
company that makes Claude, they built an
entire product, Claude Co-work, in 10
days, and they built it using Claude
code. Let that sink in. The tool you're
about to learn built another tool. While
the developers just guided it, this
isn't some side project. This is the
most powerful AI tool most people have
never heard of, and you're about to
master it.
Now, there are a lot more commands
available
/clear/compact/context/course/resume
and others. I've put together a complete
command cheat sheet. I'm sharing it in
my WhatsApp community. link is in the
description. Make sure to join. But for
building what we're building today, you
only need three commands. I'll teach you
each one as we go.
Now, before we build anything, there's
two concepts you need to understand.
Skills and agents. Back to Iron Man. You
know how Tony's suit has different
protocols? Stealth mode for
infiltration, Hulkbuster for heavy
combat, house party protocol when you
need an army. In Claude Code, those
protocols are called skills. playbooks
that tell Claude how to do specific
tasks. Need a presentation? There's a
protocol, spreadsheet protocol, PDF
protocol, and the best [music] part,
Enthropic already built a ton of these
for you. There's an entire GitHub
repository with pre-built skills ready
to go. Now, agents, remember House Party
protocol where Tony activates an entire
iron legion in Clawed Code. Agents are
your Iron Legion. Multiple AI assistants
each specialized for their mission.
Skills are the protocols. Agents are the
suits that run them. Remember that. Now
that you understand this, let's get into
part two and actually build our AI
content army. All right. So, let's start
with something simple. Research. Instead
of opening 10 tabs and copy pasting
everything, Claude Code can do all of
that for you. So, I'm just asking it to
research about Claude cowork, something
they just launched, and save everything
in a markdown file. That's it. No
complicated prompts. Just tell it what
you want and where to save it. Now, it's
asking permission to search the web.
This is ask mode doing its thing. It
checks with you before taking any
action. I'll hit allow. See, it's
pulling information from different
sources. Techrunch, Axios, Fortune,
stuff that would take you 20 to 30
minutes to read through. Claude's doing
it in seconds. It's reading through all
these articles, pulling out the
important stuff and organizing
everything for me. And look at this.
Overview, key features, use cases,
availability, everything nicely
organized. Let's check our folder. There
it is. The files been created. And
inside you've got all the research
properly formatted with all the sources
listed at the bottom. Research that
would have taken you hours done in few
minutes.
Okay, so the research is done. But
here's the thing. What if I want Claude
to remember all of this for later?
That's where the next command comes in.
It's called slashinit. Now, this is one
of the most powerful commands in claude
code. What it does is create a claude.md
file. Think of it as claude's memory.
Whatever you put in here, Claude
remembers forever. No more copy pasting
the same context over and over again.
So, I'll just type /init and hit enter.
It's asking for permission again. We'll
allow. Now, it's creating that memory
file for me. It's looking at the folder,
understanding what's in there, and
setting everything up. And there we go.
Claude.m MD file created. Let's open the
folder and see what's inside. So, it's
got the project overview, the structure,
how to work with content, everything
saved. This is stored in Claude's
memory. Next time I open this folder,
Claude already knows what's going on. No
explanations needed.
All right. So, now you've seen how the
init command works. Claude creates the
claude.m MD file and stores everything
in memory. So even if you close the app,
open a new chat, come back later, Claude
already knows what's going on. Now,
let's get into the exciting stuff.
Agents. This is where we actually create
our own specialized AI assistant. Quick
thing to use agents, you need to use the
CLI. Don't panic. You don't need to open
any scary terminal. Just click on CLI at
the bottom right of your cloud desktop.
That's it. Everything works exactly the
same. To create an agent, just type /
aents. Simple as that. Now, I'm going to
create a new one for this project.
First, it asks where to save. Project
level or personal level. Project means
it only works in this specific folder.
Personal means you can use this agent
from anywhere on your computer. I'm
keeping it at project level for now.
Now, here's the cool part. You can
either manually configure everything or
just let Claude generate the agent for
you. We're going with generate with
Claude. Way easier. So, I'm just writing
a simple prompt. Create a script writing
expert for short form content that goes
viral. Include hook, body, CTA, and
visual notes for my editor. That's it.
Now, Claude's doing all the heavy
lifting in the background. It's writing
all the rules, conditions, everything
[music] the agent needs to follow. All
from those three sentences I gave it.
Agents created. Now, it's asking about
permissions. All tools means it can
read, write, edit, delete, run code,
everything. Read only means it can only
look at stuff. For script writing, I
need it to write. So, I'm selecting all
tools. Model selection. For script
writing, I want the best output, so I'm
going with Opus. Color is just to help
you tell your agents apart. And done.
Viral short form script writer agent
created. See, it even named it for me.
Now, let's actually look at what Claude
built. So the agent file is saved in a
hidden folder called doclaude. To see
hidden folders on Mac, press command
plus shift plus period. On Windows, it's
view then hidden items. Now you can see
it. Let's open the agent file. Remember,
I only wrote three sentences. Look at
what Claude created. It's written out
everything. The entire playbook for this
agent. It's got the hook structure.
First one to 3 seconds needs to grab
attention. Body 20 to 50 seconds. And
you can even edit anything in here. Add
stuff, remove stuff, customize however
you want. It's even got visual notes for
editors, output format, how the CTA
should sound, everything. I gave it
three lines and it built this entire
system. That's the power of agents.
All right, so we've created our agents.
Now, let me show you how to actually use
them. I've set up a few different agents
for this demo. Hookw writer, script
writer, and a couple others. Let's start
with one so you can see how it works. So
here's my prompt. Write me hooks using
the research we already did. Remember
that cowwork_ressearch.md
file? I'm referencing it with the 8
symbol. Then I'm telling Claude to use
the hook agent specifically and save
everything in a new file called
hooks.md.
Hit enter and watch what happens. It's
not just following my instructions
blindly. It's actually thinking about
which agent to use. See how it first
reads the research file. Now look, I
just said hook agent, but Claude code
figured out I meant the viral hookw
writer agent we created. It's smart
enough to connect the dots. Now, while
it's working, let me explain something
important. You get 200,000 tokens per
session. Once you hit that limit, Claude
automatically compacts everything,
summarizes what you've done, and saves
it. So, you never really lose context.
It just gets compressed and done. It
created hooks.md with seven viral hooks.
Notice I never said how many hooks I
wanted. The agent just knew that giving
options is better. That's the power of a
well-built agent. Let's check the file.
There it is. Hooks.md. Opening it up.
And look at this. Hook one, hook two,
all the way to seven. Different types of
hooks, why it works, and what type of
content it's best for. So, the agent
didn't just write hooks. It explained
the strategy behind each one all from
one simple prompt. So, we've used one
agent. Now, let me show you where it
gets really powerful. Using multiple
agents all working together. Here's what
I'm doing. The research is done. The
hooks are ready. Now, I want a full
script. So, I'm telling Claude to use
all the files we created, the research
file and the hooks file. But here's the
thing. I'm not using just one agent. I'm
chaining three agents together. First,
the storytelling agent creates the
narrative structure. Then, that output
goes to my YouTube analyst agent. This
one knows my tone of voice, the words I
use, everything about my style. And
finally, all of that goes to the script
writer agent for the final output. Now,
watch what Claw does. It's not running
all three at once. It's smart enough to
go one after the other. Takes the output
from the first agent, feeds it to the
second, then to the third, just like an
assembly line. Quick tip. If you want
things to run parallel, you can do that,
too. Like sending three research agents
to search Instagram, LinkedIn, and
Reddit all at the same time. Saves a ton
of time. Now, here's something important
about tokens. The agent used 15,000
tokens, but my main chat only used
4,000. Each agent gets its own fresh
200,000 tokens. So, if I had done all
this research and writing in my main
[music] chat, I would have burned
through my entire limit. But with
agents, everything stays efficient. The
YouTube analyst is done. Now it's
passing everything to the script writer.
The one we built earlier. Let it do its
thing and done. It's asking permission
to save the script. I'll allow. Now
let's see what we got. Look at this
complete YouTube script on Claude
co-work.
Video title, core transformation for
viewers, everything. And remember the
agents worked with each other
automatically. I didn't have to copy
paste anything between them. We've got
the hook, act one, act two, the demo
section, retention hooks throughout,
plus all the visual notes for my editor
that I asked for, a complete expert
level script, and look, it even added an
emotional arc showing how the viewer
should feel throughout the video. On top
of that, title and thumbnail options.
The agent went above and beyond. You get
all this output without burning through
your main context. That's your AI
content army. research hooks, full
scripts, all done automatically while
you just sit back and watch. So, we
finally did it. From being scared of
that word code and thinking Claude code
is only meant for developers to building
a full army of AI agents all working
together writing viral scripts on
autopilot. Let's recap the three
commands that built your entire Iron
Legion. Command number one /init gave
Jarvis permanent memory. Command number
two / agents deployed your Iron Legion.
Command number three at targeted your
files. Three commands. That's all it
took. Now I want you to actually start
using it. Go unlock these superpowers
and become 100 times more productive.
This one tool will help you get ahead of
99% of people. Most people don't even
know this exists and you've already
mastered it. When it becomes mainstream,
the new normal, you're way ahead. And
look, there's so much more I couldn't
cover. custom skills, MCPS, automations.
If you want a video on that, drop it in
the comments and I'll make it happen.
All right, go build your AI army.